face à face les duels s'enchaînent sur
cet estrade du gymnase Philippe pivert
de Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'est ici que
la Fédération Française de force
organise le championnat de France de
bras de fer ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que c'est le premier vrai type de
championne de champion de France puisque
la Fédération Française de force a eu la
délégation du ministère en fin d'année
dernière pour pouvoir organiser les
championnats de France donc aujourd'hui
ça va être les premiers vrais types de
champion de France qui vont être donnés
par la Fédération au total 170
participants s'affrontent dans
différentes catégories selon leur âge et
leur poids et dans chacune d'elles il y
a un champion bras gauche et un autre
bras droit et peu importe son bras
dominant ce sport nécessite certes de la
force mais aussi de la technique c'est
un sport qui demande beaucoup de
d'applications au niveau des
entraînements niveau pour justement
renforcer ses tendons
aussi il y a énormément de techniques ça
me paraît rien mais c'est c'est partir
en top rôle partir en août il y a la
presse il y a elle est à la poussée la
side donc c'est vraiment énormément de
choses qui s'apprennent au long terme on
s'imagine bras de fer sport de de brut
de costaud non c'est un sport à part
entière ces techniques il y a une table
normée il y a un arbitrage il y a des
règles à respecter ça demande des
qualités mais plus que de la force il y
a de la technique et de la rapidité il y
a le mental mais c'est énorme je veux
dire le mental fait que si la tête est
là et le physique n'y est pas bon c'est
pas pareil si le physique qui est mais
la tête n'y est pas la victoire tu
l'auras peut-être pas quoi le bras de
fer est en plein développement certains
athlètes professionnels commencent même
à gagner leur vie grâce à ce sport il
pourrait faire son apparition aux Jeux
olympiques en 2028